-It's time for "Tonight Show
Hashtags." Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
This week,
I sent out the hashtag...
[ Laughter ]
I asked you guys to share
your funniest New Year's
resolution using just six words.
Within minutes, it was
the number 1 trending topic.
[ Cheering and applause ]
So thank you.
Thank you for playing along.
We appreciate you guys
doing this.
I love this.
I'd like to share some
of my favorite responses
from you guys.
Here we go.
Six words, here we go.
This one's from @amysrich.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you go. That's
exactly right.
-Yeah, got to get the grapes.
-This one is
from @Optimist-Eeyore.
-Oh.
-She says...
There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Same month.
-"I'm going to do it, man."
-This one's from @ponyglasses.
[ Laughter ]
She says...
-Ponyglasses?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
-This one's a nice one.
This is from @eddielovestoast.
[ Laughter ]
-He does love toast.
-He says...
There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thanks, buddy.
"I got to go on Hulu, man."
-Come on, man.
-Yeah, come on.
This one's from @ducktor-who10.
He says...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Wow!
Well, you can tell by the way
he uses his walk.
-"Ah, ha, ha, ha,
stayin' alive."
So good.
That's my favorite one.
This one is
from @RealBillRussell.
NBA legend Bill Russell
-Whoa!
-from the Celtics.
-Come on.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Love you, Bill Russell!
[ Laughs ]
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
When you get older,
you get shorter.
That's what happens.
-He's only 6'8."
-Yeah.
This last one here is
from @AnnaLouMazzei.
She says...
-Yeah!
-There you go, right there.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites, go to...